yeah for sure yeah I felt a lot of  support and everything because I always  check my messages from people and I love  seeing people telling me how supportive  they are of me and what I'm doing and  just to be able to know that you're an  inspiration to kids and everything  that's it's a pretty great feeling I  don't usually turn off my phone but it  was like crashing a lot and it turned  itself off so that was a little weird  for me but um no I guess it's kind of  cool too I guess Rio was kind of just a  test out the waters for me and for 2016  and I was looking more for 20-22 medal i  guess but to be able to come out of Rio  and have a gold medal it just it's  setting the bar pretty high for me I  guess for 2020 well if this is just  testing out the water is that I can't  imagine what 2020 will be like I don't  know yet I don't know if I could say  that was testing out the waters anymore  but I guess it's definitely boosted my  confidence in to 2020